hey everyone i'm abby sharp today we're
going to be doing something a little bit
different we're gonna do a vlog cooking
style video which i haven't done in a
really long time
other than my what ate in a days and i
know that a lot of other youtubers and
creators are doing these kind of
quarantine edition 1-8 in a day videos
but i just felt like that was gonna be a
little disruptive to my whole family
because nobody can really leave the
house right now and we also have some
extra guests staying with us so instead
i wanted to share with you four easy
recipes using your pantry staples and
your freezer staples things that you've
probably kind of accumulated after one
of your big grocery hauls and you're not
sure what to do with them so all of four
of these recipes breakfast lunch dinner
and dessert are completely plant-based
so hopefully i'll be able to share a
little bit of inspiration give you some
ideas of what to do because for a lot of
you you know you might be cooking every
single meal for yourself you you're not
going out you're not ordering in and
that can be really stressful I know for
me I'm doing all the cooking in the
house and even just the meal planning is
so overwhelming to be thinking so far in
advance about every single ingredient
and every single snack or every single
drink that we may want in that week so
hopefully this gives you some ideas and
of course I'm going to leave all of
these recipes in the description below
so you can definitely check that out
alright now without further ado let's
get to this
okay so first we're gonna do my protein
packed stuff sweet potato and I know a
lot of you loved the idea that I had in
one of my other videos about adding in
some white beans to avocado to boost up
the protein in avocado toast so I'm
always trying to think about ways to add
protein to the breakfast meal that does
not necessarily need or require eggs or
Greek yogurt or protein powder so this
might be a really fun hack that you'll
be doing a lot well in isolation let's
get to it
okay so first thing I did is I literally
just stuck my sweet potato in the
microwave until it was like really
really soft you can also bake them at
like a 350 degrees and I'll probably
take about
so and I'm gonna carefully try to scoop
out the cooked flesh okay next I've just
got some very soft tofu this is going to
be the protein of course and if I was
making this like in a big batch I would
use an entire brick of tofu for about
four sweet potatoes but you'll all leave
the recipe of course in the description
below then I've got some natural peanut
butter or almond butter any kind of nut
butter I'm just gonna add a little bit
of flavor
we've got some cinnamon here any kind of
baking Spicewood be lovely here and a
pinch of salt and then I'm just going to
puree that until really smooth okay so
that is what you're looking for now we
basically are east of the sweet potato
[Music]
okay so honestly that sweet potato is
delicious all on its own and in fact if
you don't even want to stuff the sweet
potato again you can just like eat that
almost like an alternative to yogurt or
oatmeal it is truly truly delicious but
I like to top mine off with a little bit
of chia jam which again this is
something that I make pretty much every
single week and now that you have
probably a lot of frozen fruits in the
freezer this is a really great way to
use it up so I'm going to show you how I
make it with cherries but really any
kind of fruit would work okay so I've
got some frozen sour cherries here you
can use like I said any kind of frozen
fruit or sweet cherries those are going
in and I'm just going to give that a
minute
to heat up until they start to basically
melt down you can also give them a
little bit of a mash to kind of break
them up a little bit I'm also going to
add in a little bit of lime juice but
you could use lemon juice I usually lose
used lemon juice but I don't have any
lemons so lime it is lime and cherries
are delicious
now if you're using regular cherries as
probably isn't an issue but if your
cherries are a little sour like mine you
can add like a little bit of maple syrup
to taste just to sweeten okay so my
cherries have cooked down nicely I'm
just going to put them into a little jar
container and I'm gonna add in some
white cheese seats you can use black
cheese seeds but I have quite a house so
definitely one of my major pantry
staples is chia so basically you just
let this sit overnight and I have a
batch ready to go so I will assemble
this breakfast alright so we've got our
finished set chia jam here and like I
said I always have this in the fridge
for toast or au meal or yogurt or things
like this so let's give a good dollop on
top I've also got a few extra sour
cherries that I just thought out have a
little peanut butter drizzle and because
I put hemp arts on basically everything
a little bit of that voila that is your
easy pantry freezer staple breakfast
alright folks we have accomplished
breakfast let's move on to lunch now
we're gonna make this like so super
simple ten minute tortilla soup and I'm
making this completely vegan and
plant-based but on my blog I actually
have it so that you would add in like a
pulled rotisserie chicken to again make
it like a crazy easy weeknight meal so
if you eat chicken then feel free to
throw some chicken in actually if you're
picking up a rotisserie chicken from the
grocery store this reheating method as
making it into a soup would be a great
way to ensure that it is like fully safe
to eat so but like I said this version
is going to be completely plant-based
but of course adjust based on what you
have in the pantry fridge and freezer
well let's get to it
okay so to our soup pot I've just got
some jarred salsa you can also use
homemade if you have it already but
again we're talking about pantry staples
making things super simple super easy
this is a crazy easy hack so we've got
jarred salsa going in and that already
has like your onions and your garlic
like sauteed so you've skipped that step
so that's going in we've got a can of
black beans that I've just drained and
rinsed really really really really well
that goes in we've got some veggie stock
you can use chicken stock especially if
you're adding chicken to this of course
got some tomato paste just to boost up
the tomato flavor another pantry staple
I always have tomato paste there's so
many recipes that would call for it
we've got a little bit of cumin and no
this is not sponsored cumin and a little
bit of chili if you want to make this
super super mild of course you could
omit the chili then a little bit of lime
juice and limes if you don't have space
for them in the fridge that's okay you
can leave them in the pantry alright so
we're just gonna give this a nice little
stir let it heat up a bit
and once that comes to a simmer then
we're gonna add in our veg okay so now
that this has come together I have a lot
of frozen vegetables in my freezer right
now and I'm always trying to figure out
what to do with them
so that they don't taste like crap and I
find that soups are actually one of the
best ways to use frozen vegetables so
I've got some frozen bell peppers here
that can go in and of course lots of
frozen corn and this is a super
versatile recipe so of course use
whatever frozen veggies you happen to
have in abundance in your freezer but
literally because they're basically
already like flash frozen and precooked
this is just going to take a second to
warm through okay so that was how easy
that was it literally took me ten
minutes to make a gorgeous veggie packed
soup and if you want to of course make
it more Instagram Abal I've got a little
bit of vegan sour cream or vegan yogurt
of course we got some Avvo I'm gonna eat
this piece and a little bit of cilantro
on top
[Music]
all right loves we are back in it's time
for dinner and we're gonna be making an
unstuffed cabbage roll in a bowl and I
love cabbage rolls traditional cabbage
rolls with the rice and and the meat and
the sauce all in the cabbage and it's
kinda like a sweetened and tangy sauce
it's delicious but I do not have time to
be stuffing cabbage rolls right now and
you guys probably don't either so this
is a really quick e-version and it's
almost like a deconstructed cabbage roll
and of course we're making a completely
plant-based so well let's get to it
okay so into our pot I'm just gonna add
a little bit of olive oil over like a
medium-high heat or so and I'm gonna add
in some onion and a little bit of garlic
that I've just chopped up here let's
give that a moment to become aromatic
and break down a little bit okay next
I'm adding in some green cabbage that
I've just chopped up nice and into small
little chunks like that basically
[Music]
okay so now we're gonna add in our
Tomatoes so I've got some canned
tomatoes I've actually drained most of
the liquid a little bit is gonna be
still left behind but I'm gonna mainly
add in the tomato pieces and then if we
need more liquid we can add that at the
end I've got some tomato sauce here a
little bit of maple syrup you can also
use brown sugar or any other kind of
sweetener you like apple cider vinegar
and a little aged balsamic vinegar now
I'm just gonna season with a little bit
of salt and a little bit of pepper and
we'll give it a good stir I'm now gonna
just pop the lid on and let that simmer
for about 15 minutes until the cabbage
softens up okay so after about 15
minutes the cabbage has softened nicely
and has been coated in the beautiful
sweet tomato sauce and the sauce is
almost like caramelized a little bit
because of that aged balsamic and a
little bit of maple syrup or sugar in
there okay so your last step is just add
some of this veggie ground round it's
basically like already cooked it's like
a soy based meat but if you want to use
regular ground beef or ground turkey or
ground chicken just make sure that
you've cooked it before you add it in at
this step because it's really just a
quick quick little stir around as we
you're gonna add it in here so let me go
I'm just gonna break it up a little bit
and then get it evenly distributed
throughout
all right friends that is the final
product and it's so easy so simple made
with a cabbage that will literally last
weeks in the pantry all right so to
serve I've just added a base of some
quinoa because that's the pantry staple
that I have a lot of but you could
always use rice or any other green and
then we've talked it off with our
deconstructed cabbage roll filling a
little bit of parsley and
[Music]
all right friends we are now going to
make my favorite part of everyday
dessert we're going to do tahini stuffed
chocolate dipped dates hello so these
are really really delicious and actually
all the ingredients came out of my
pantry so you probably have a lot of the
same kinds of ingredients in your pantry
right now and if you don't a lot of them
are really easy to swap in with other
nuts and nut butters and ingredients so
let's get to this okay so the first
thing I need to do is just pit these
dates because yeah we got to make room
for some yummy tahini and nobody wants
to eat a date pit unless you're my dog
puppy in which case hey one time she got
an entire box of dates ate the entire
thing pit and all it was probably not a
very pleasant day for her to go to the
bathroom but then like a week later she
did the same thing
so I guess glutton for punishment right
can't be that bad
so like you could see I'm trying not to
completely break them in half just break
into them gently and get the pit out
this one I had nope it weird very weird
alright next step okay so we've got some
gorgeous delicious thick tahini right
here and I'm going to add in some
crushed pistachios and give that a nice
little stir carefully because of course
I chose a vessel that is way too small
to do this elegantly now cuz pie like
little sweet ends kind of savory
combination gonna add in a little bit of
fleur de sel just to flavor up my tahini
here and now it's time to stuff okay so
get your date get a little dollop of
your tahini
[Music]
squish it in there gorgeous this is a
messy job so if you have to lick your
fingers I'm not gonna judge you okay so
next up we're just going to take our
stuff - he need eights
pop them on a baking sheet lines a
little bit of parchment paper and then
I'm going to put them in the freezer for
about 10 minutes just to set up
[Music]
okay so now is the fun step we've got
our dates our stuffed dates we've got
some melted chocolate but I just put in
the microwave you could do it in a
double boiler if you prefer we're going
to give it a good coat fit down on your
tray a little fleur de sel a little
crushed pistachios and a little sesame
seeds so gorgeous let's make some more
all right and they are all done and
since they were already pretty cold
before we started to add the chocolate
they're basically just going to set on
their own but if you're not going to eat
them immediately definitely pop them
into the fridge alright folks that is it
we've got breakfast lunch dinner and
dessert all using really simple
ingredients that you probably have in
your pantry your freezer and your fridge
from your big kovat nineteen grocery
hauls I hope that these recipes give you
a little bit of inspiration and help
take some of the stress away from meal
planning during these already crazy
chaotic times also a big heads up we've
got lots of other recipes on my blog
Abbey's kitchen so definitely check out
the link below and if you're not already
follow me on my Instagram at Abbey's
kitchen I am sharing my personal weekly
menu just based on what I've got in my
freezer and when I plan to pick up each
week when I do my grocery delivery haul
on that note if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below about any other kind of
content that you want to see more of if
you have any pantry staples or freezer
staples that you want to see me turn
into a meal leave me a comment below and
I will try to do that either on my blog
or over here at Abbey's kitchen on
YouTube subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]